>> Tucker: MIKE TYSON IS NOT THE
SORT OF PERSON THAT WE GENERALLY
INTERVIEW.
HE'S NOT A POLITICAL FIGURE.
HE'S NOT STILL BOXING.
WHY DO WE TALK TO HIM?
BECAUSE MIKE TYSON HAS SPENT
ALMOST 40 YEARS AT THE PINNACLE
OF AMERICAN SOCIETY.
AND AT THE BOTTOM.
HE'S SEEN EVERYTHING.
HE'S WHEN TO PRISON.
PEOPLE THAT LEAD LIVES LIKE THAT
ARE DESTROYED BY THEM.
THEY BECOME NUMB AND INCENSABLE.
A RARE FEW BECOME WISE AND
FASCINATING.
AND ABLE TO COMMUNICATE.
TYSON IS IN THAT CATEGORY.
WE SAT DOWN WITH TYSON AND WE
BEGAN BY ASKING HIM WHAT WAS IT
LIKE GROWING UP?
HERE'S PART OF THAT.
>> I'M PROUD OF MY CHILDHOOD.
>> Tucker: BUT NO ADVANTAGES?
>> YEAH, MY DISADVANTAGE WAS MY
ADVANTAGE.
>> Tucker: WHAT DO YOU MEAN?
>> MY ADVERSITY.
INSPIRED ME TO BE MORE THAN WHAT
I WAS.
>> Tucker: I BELIEVE THAT.
SO YOU ARE INSPIRED BY ALI.
YOU GO TO A DIFFERENT REFORM
SCHOOL.
THEY HAVE A FORMER FIGHTER THERE
THAT TRAINS YOU IS.
THAT THE POINT THAT YOU REALIZE
YOU'RE GOING TO DO THIS FOR A
LIVING?
>> YEAH, I CAME THERE.
I WAS ON ANOTHER CAMPUS.
I DON'T BELIEVE I STABBED
SOMEBODY.
I HAD AN ALTERCATION.
I HAD HANDCUFFS AND ARRESTED.
I WAS A MESS.
SO WHEN THE GUYS ARE TALKING TO
ME BECAUSE THEY SAID YOU'RE NOT
A BAD GUY BECAUSE YOU DID THAT.
HE SAID WE HAVE EX-FIGHTER.
YOU NEED TO MEET HIM.
HE WILL GET YOU IN SHAPE.
I SAID I SEEN MOHAMMED ALI ONCE.
HE SAID I HEARD YOU WANT TO
TALK.
WHAT DO YOU WANT?
I WANT TO BE A FIGHTER.
EVERYBODY WANTS TO SEE A
FIGHTER.
I WENT FROM BEING A NASTY GUY TO
BECOMING AN A STUDENT.
HE STARTED TRAINING ME.
>> Tucker: WAS IT THE DISCIPLINE
THAT HE IMPOSED?
>> YES.
I WANTED TO BE A FIGHTER SO BAD.
>> Tucker: IF YOU HADN'T BEEN A
PROFESSIONAL BOXER, WHAT WOULD
YOU HAVE BECOME?
>> THERE'S NO DOUBT.
>> Tucker: AT WHAT AGE?
>> 13.
14.
>> Tucker: AND FOUR YEARS LATER
YOU WERE.
>> SEVEN YEARS LATER.
>> Tucker: SEVEN YEARS LATER.
SO WHEN DID YOU MUST CUSTAMADO?
>> WHEN I WAS 12.
I WAS AT THE FACILITY.
THE GUY DROVE ME TO MEET HIM.
I WAS A TRUSTEE NOW.
I WAS A GOOD KID.
I COULD GO TO -- GET OFF CAMPUS
AND GO VISIT THEM.
>> Tucker: WHAT WAS HE LIKE?
>> TOTAL DISCIPLINARIAN.
TAKE NO [BLEEP].
THAT'S WHAT I NEED.
>> Tucker: NOT A WEAK MAN.
>> NO SIGNS OF WEAKNESS.
NO SIGNS OF WEAKNESS.
IF YOU DIDN'T CONDUCT THE WAY HE
DID, YOU'RE NOT ITALIAN.
HE'S GOING TO TELL YOU WHAT
ITALIAN IS.
IF HE THOUGHT LIKE -- ONE OF
THOSE GUYS -- WHAT WAS THE PAULY
NAME?
THE JERSEY SHORE GUYS.
THEY'RE NOT ITALIAN.
HE WOULD SAY SOMETHING LIKE
THAT.
IF YOU DON'T KNOW -- ITALIANS
CONDUCT THEMSELVES LIKE THIS.
HE'S NOT ITALIAN.
HE WAS THAT KIND OF GUY.
>> Tucker: AMAZING.
>> NOTHING PLAYFUL.
NOTHING PLAYFUL ABOUT HIM.
>> Tucker: AND YOU LIKED THAT.
>> I LOVED HIM.
SOMEONE CARED ABOUT ME.
IF ANYBODY SAID SOMETHING TO ME,
I'D PUNCH THEM IN THE FACE,
ATTACK THEM.
>> Tucker: SO INTERESTING.
MOST PEOPLE --
>> HE AIN'T SAYING NOTHING ABOUT
ME.
HE WOULD ATTACK YOU PHYSICALLY.
>> Tucker: WERE YOU EVER AFRAID?
>> ALWAYS AFRAID OF HIM.
I'M AFRAID OF HIM NOW.
TAKE THAT.
HE MADE SURE YOU'RE AFRAID OF
HIM.
>> Tucker: AND YOU LIKED THAT.
>> LISTEN, WE WERE ON THE THIRD
FLOOR.
WE'RE TALKING CRAP?
YEAH, TALKING ABOUT GIRLS.
HE COME UPSTAIRS.
EVERYBODY STOPS TALKING.
HE SAID HEY, I HEARD EVERYBODY
LAUGHING.
I WANT TO KNOW WHAT WAS FUNNY.
I WANT TO LAUGH, TOO.
NOTHING.
WE WERE JUST TALKING.
HE WAS ALWAYS ON OUR BACK.
IF WE TOLD HIM WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT GIRLS, YOU HAVE TO GET
GIRLS OFF OF YOUR MIND.
HOW CAN YOU BE CHAMPION THINKING
ABOUT GIRLS?
WE NEVER TOLD HIM.
WE WERE UP HERE TALKING.
I WANT TO KNOW.
YOU GUYS WERE LAUGHING.
HOW COME YOU STOPPED LAUGHING?
WHY?
YOU'RE SCARED TO DEATH TO SO I
ANYTHING.
>> Tucker: BUT YOU WERE LIKE
TWICE AS BIG AS HIM.
>> THAT DON'T MEAN NOTHING.
HE HAD THE SYSTEM OF
INTIMIDATION DOWN LIKE A
SCIENCE.
>> Tucker: REALLY?
>> DOWN TO A SCIENCE.
>> Tucker: WHAT WERE HIS
METHODS?
>> NOT TALKING.
GUARD LANGUAGE IS LANGUAGE
WITHOUT MAKING SOUNDS.
YOU UNDERSTAND WHEN HE'S MAD OR
NOT.
>> Tucker: LOOK AT THAT.
>> I'M A LITTLE BOY.
SO HAPPY TO BE WITH THIS GUYS.
LOOK HOW BIG I AM AT 14.
>> Tucker: YOU WERE 14 THERE?
>> YEAH.
LOOK HOW BIG I AM.
>> Tucker: YOU WERE ENORMOUS.
>> BABY HUEY.
>> Tucker: PARDON MY BAD MEMORY.
DID HE LIVE TO SEE YOU BECOME --
>> NO.
HE DIED A YEAR BEFORE.
LESS THAN A YEAR.
>> Tucker: REALLY?
>> EIGHT, NINE MONTHS.
SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
>> Tucker: HE WAS YOUR GUARDIAN?
>> YEAH.
MY MOTHER SIGNED ME OVER TO HIM
BEFORE SHE DIED.
>> Tucker: HOW OLD WERE YOU WHEN
SHE DIED?
>> 16.
>> Tucker: 16.
HE WASN'T JUST YOUR COACH.
HE WAS YOUR MENTOR --
>> YEAH, IF I DIDN'T MAKE IT IN
FIGHTING, I STILL HAD TO BE
THERE.
>> Tucker: DID YOU LIVE WITH
HIM?
>> YEAH, 13.
>> Tucker: YOU LIVED
HOUSE?
>> YEAH.
>> Tucker: THAT'S SO DIFFERENT.
>> LISTEN, ANY TIME I SAW A
WHITE GUY WITH A JUDGE, A COP,
HE WAS A VICTIM.
I COME THIS GUY'S HOUSE AND THIS
GUY SHOWED ME LOVE.
LOVE IS POWERFUL.
>> Tucker: ONE OF THE REASONS I
WANTED TO INTERVIEW YOU IS
BECAUSE YOU'RE THE AUTHOR OF ONE
OF MY FAVORITE QUOTES IN
ENGLISH.
EVERYBODY HAS A PLAN UNTIL THEY
GET HIT IN THE FACE.
>> 100%, ESPECIALLY NOW, NOBODY
FIGHTS.
THEY TALK.
THEY GET ON YOUTUBE AND START
TALKING.
SOME PEOPLE ARE NOT MADE FOR
HANDLING CRITICISM.
THEY JUST NOT MADE FOR IT.
SOME PEOPLE GO OFF THE DEEP END
WHEN YOU CRITICIZE THEM.
THEY CAN'T HANDLE IT.
SOME OF THE MOST POWERFUL PEOPLE
IN THE WORLD CAN'T HANDLE IT.
THEY'RE NOT MATURE ENOUGH TO
HANDLE CRITICISM.
>> Tucker: HAVE YOU GOTTEN
BETTER HANDLING CRITICISM AS
YOU'VE GOTTEN OLDER?
>> YES.
BUT MOSTLY -- YEAH.
STILL -- IT CAN GET EVEN BETTER.
SOMETIMES I GET IN MY HEAD AND I
THINK I'M SOMEBODY.
THAT I'M EASILY OFFENDED.
WHEN I KNEW I'M NOBODY, I COULD
NEVER BE OFFENDED.
>> Tucker: IS THAT A DEEP
INSIGHT.
SOMETIMES I GET IN MY HEAD THAT
I'M SOMEBODY AND EASILY OFFENDED
AND I REMIND MYSELF THAT I'M
NOBODY AND I'M NOT OFFENDED.
>> EXACTLY.
>> Tucker: IF YOU'RE THAT
WELL-KNOWN, PEOPLE ARE SUCKING
UP TO YOU, TAKING PICTURES OF
YOU.
HOW DO YOU REMIND YOURSELF THAT
ACTUALLY I'M NOBODY?
>> WELL, I DON'T KNOW.
GOD DID THIS.
I ASKED FOR THIS AND THIS IS
WHAT HE GAVE ME.
IT'S NOT LIKE SOMEBODY GAVE ME
SOMETHING I DIDN'T ACQUIRE.
I WANTED THIS LIFE.
I PRAYED FOR THIS LIFE AND I
RECEIVED IT.
>> Tucker: WHEN I THINK I'M
SOMEBODY, I'M OFFENDED.
WHEN I REMEMBER I'M NOBODY, I'M
NOT.
THERE'S A LOT MORE IN THAT VEIN.
TOMORROW TYSON TALK ABOUT HIS
FAITH AND LOVE OF ANIMALS.
ONE OF THE MOST REMARKABLE
CONVERSATIONS WE'VE EVER HAD.
THEN HE DESCRIBES HOW HE FELT
ABOUT THE MEN HE FOUGHT IN THE
RING OVER THE YEARS.
WE'LL GIVE YOU A PREVIEW.
I WANTED TO KI